now I would say all good things come to
an end but I'm not sure I can call this
a good thing anymore so there was a
little bit of information that Krysten
Ritter dropped talking about the new
season of Jessica Jones which as of the
time that I'm recording this particular
video is I've seen the first three
episodes of the second season and I'll
probably have watched more by the time
this video actually goes out but she
said that there probably isn't gonna be
another defenders and I would say at
this point it is looking a lot like the
entire Marvel Netflix thing is just
gonna wrap up and get closed and that's
not excessively shocking because this
wasn't something that Disney could just
move over to its streaming service that
it's starting up in a couple of years
because they don't that this was a
co-production with Netflix itself they
would have to completely buyout
Netflix's share of ownership of these
things in order to be able to do
anything with it and it may not be worth
it to them and the first place to go
ahead and do that but it also makes it
so there there isn't a lot of impetus
for for them to keep this going over a
Netflix because they are gonna be having
their own streaming service and they'll
probably just start from scratch over
there and so like I said it's not it's
not a huge shock when you take all that
into account so I guess the first
question is okay well what if we're not
getting another season of defenders what
will we get what we know we're getting
season three of daredevil where you
should be getting a second season of
Luke Cage apparently they're really
gonna do a second season of iron fist I
don't know why but for my money that's
it we get season three of daredevil
season 2 of Luke Cage season 2 of iron
fist and unless there's a really high
demand that'll probably be it like maybe
a movie to close out
dangling threads across the series that
might be left at that point that's
slightly iffy I think but I think that's
gonna be it
Oh Punisher will die they may or may not
have announced the second season of
Punisher put a maybe on that one
so yeah the whole thing I think it's
just gonna wrap up and speaking
personally I'm really kind of okay with
that the shine really came off these
Netflix projects for me well I think it
came out firmly with the defenders but
the decline started well before that
because first there was daredevil season
2 which had a weak seconds in second
half of the season and then there was
Luke Cage which had a weak second half
of the season then there was iron fist
which was just terrible and then there
was the defenders which started out fine
and then went to utter crap by the time
it was finished and at this point there
are only two seasons of the stuff that's
gone out so far that I genuinely enjoy
first season of daredevil first season
of Jessica Jones and as I said I'm only
three episodes into Jessica Jones season
2 as of this recording but I'm not
loving it so far and I'm not
exceptionally hopeful that it's gonna
get better
so under other circumstances I might be
bemoaning the fact that we'd be losing
you know the the harsher ground-level
Marvel stuff that's over on Netflix but
at this point I'm kind of not that's not
to say that I wouldn't appreciate
something else coming in to fill that
niche in some form whether Disney allows
for some for some harsher characters to
take up in the form in movies we
probably won't get anything this harsh
on the Disney streaming service because
they've kind of indicated they don't
want to do our rated material on that
but I don't have a problem with this
ending at this whole experiment again I
do hope something fills the niche
because I do like the idea of
harsher gritty ground-level stuff but
this particular Netflix averse the
diminishing returns that that happened
in hindsight relatively quickly and at
this point that I if I hadn't already
loved the first season of Jessica Jones
I would be tempted to not watch any more
of the second of the second season it if
the second season was the first season I
might stop oh where I am right now so
the the whole thing honestly I'm not
entirely sure what went wrong I if I
were to guess I think somewhere along
the line somebody thought that their big
hook ins were gonna be sort of mystery
elements you know big mysterious
organizations like the hand like the
whatever wherever Luke Cage got his
powers from whoever caused Jessica Jones
to get her powers except all this stuff
has been massively uninteresting every
time they've gone into it the hand
especially where they've sunk a heck of
a lot of time in and you know I think is
where with the movies they decided that
US was going to be sort of the
connective Villain tissue to some degree
across a lot of the films I think they
decided that these shadowy organizations
were going to be the villain connective
tissue for the Netflix shows and that
just has not panned out and honestly the
more I think about it I'm not sure evil
corporations and corporate entities and
these sorts of shadowy organizations
actually work particularly well like
just in general has narrative devices
because it's like oh you don't know what
they're capable of like but then by the
time you show me it's jits pretty
run-of-the-mill it's you is either
pretty run the middle of pretty basic or
you try and keep it mysterious the whole
time and then I'm just frustrated going
what somehow the hand managed to do both
I don't even know so yeah I do I do I
would not be shocked if within a year we
get an announcement of the ending of the
Marvel Netflix franchises and whether
those shows specifically I do not expect
to continue obviously Marvel has the
rights to the characters still so
exactly how I I would imagine they
couldn't continue those specific shows
without involving Netflix in them but I
would not I would not hold my breath for
new shows featuring these characters or
for them to suddenly start turning up at
the movies it's possible I would be
really really surprised to though so I
think we all need to make peace with the
fact that we will soon be saying goodbye
to Matt Murdock Luke Cage Jessica Jones
Danny Rand and Frank Castle and and
that's kind of a shame but only for me
at least on paper because this
ultimately didn't become what it started
out as and what I think it could have
been so what are your thoughts on the
possibility of Marvel Netflix shows just
coming to a close do you think it's a
good thing do you think it's a bad thing
what shows are you gonna miss what do
you hope that they do before things
close out do you think I'm nuts and this
is actually gonna keep going whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do like support me on
patreon and follow me on Twitter listen
to my podcast by t-shirt links for all
this stuff is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]